in michigan we lead by over 35 000 votes
and is growing a substantially bigger
margin
and president trump won michigan in
2016.
michigan will complete his vote soon
maybe as early as the day and i feel
very good
about pennsylvania virtually all the
remaining battles to be counted
were cast by mail and we've been winning
78 of the votes by mail
in pennsylvania we've flipped arizona
and the second district of nebraska of
special significance to me
is that we've won with the majority of
the american people
and every indication is that the
majority will grow
we have a popular vote lead of nearly 3
million votes
and every indication is that will grow
as well
indeed senator harris and i are on track
to win more votes than any ticket in the
history of this country
that ever won the presidency and vice
presidency
over 70 million votes i'm very proud of
our campaign
only three presidential campaigns in the
past
have defeated an incumbent president
when it's finished
god willing will be the fourth this is a
major achievement
this is a major achievement and it's
been a long and difficult campaign
but it's been a more difficult time
for our country a hard time
we've had a hard campaigns before
we've faced hard times before so once
this election
is finalized and behind us it'll be time
for us to do what we've always
done as americans to put the harsh
rhetoric
of the campaign behind us to lower the
temperature
to see each other again to listen to one
another
tweet to hear each other again
and respect and care for one another
to unite to heal
to come together as a nation
i know this won't be easy i'm not naive
neither of us are i know how deep and
hard the opposing views are
in our country on so many things but i
also know this as well
to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents
as enemies we are not enemies
what brings us together as americans is
so much stronger
than anything that can tear us apart so
let me be clear
i we are campaigning as a democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
the president the presidency itself is
not
a partisan institution it's the one
office
in this nation that represents everyone
and it demands a duty of care for
all americans that is precisely what i
will do
i'll i will work as hard for those who
didn't vote for me
as it will for those who did vote for me
now every vote must be counted no one's
going to take our democracy away from us
not now not ever america has come
too far america's fought too many
battles
america's endured too much ever let that
happen
we the people will not be silenced
we the people will not be bullied
we the people will not surrender
my friends i'm confident will emerge
victorious
but this will not be
my victory loan or our victory loan
it'll be a victory for the american
people
for our democracy for america
and there will be no blue states and red
states
when we win just the united states of
america
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you